hello it's good to be with you I'm gonna
come at this a slightly different way
from the previous folks that's largely
because I have never invented anything
never started a company I've never made
a great scientific breakthrough I don't
have a grand theory of the universe what
I want to do here though this morning
this afternoon is I tell you a story
that's all I want to do I'm gonna tell
you one story with one lesson and the
story is about
I need a drone to move this thing here
we go
stories about these guys andre gaim
konstantin novoselov
andre Guymon konstantin novoselov how
many of you see a show of hands how many
have heard of andre gan and konstantin
novoselov let's see a show of hands it
looks like less than half of you have
heard of Andre GaN and Konstantin
Novoselov let me tell you about them 18
months ago they won the Nobel Prize in
Physics they isolated something called
graphene now graphene is a mate it's
extraordinary graphene is a substance
that is one atom thick okay I mean I
can't even do it that's you know one
atom thick and it's something like 70 or
80 times the strength of steel right you
think whoa I think I read something
about that in Harry Potter you know it's
like it seems almost fantastical right
so obviously huge implications for
material science is one of the biggest
breakthroughs in material science in
several generations to show you here's
what one of their colleagues said just
to give you a sense of the awesomeness
of this discovery here's what they one
of their colleagues says if scaled up to
the thickness of plastic refrigerator
wrap a sheet of graphene stretched over
a coffee cup could support the weight of
a truck bearing down on up pencil point
okay pretty good so the story is about
how did they make this breakthrough on
graphene how did they do something so
extraordinary but I'll get to that in a
moment but first I have a question for
all of you here's little show hands here
how many of you another show of hands
how many of you have an iPad okay now
how many of you knew three years ago you
were missing an iPad that's actually
actually have a very serious question
because at some level that's what
disruption which we've been talking
about yes
disruption is about giving people
something they didn't know they were
missing right that's what I mean people
didn't know they were missing that cool
vacuum cleaner people didn't know they
were missing Kickstarter people didn't
know back in 1990 I didn't know back in
1991 that I was missing a web browser
that's what disruption is giving the
world something it didn't know it was
missing to my mind and actually Dyson
was talking about this the same time
that's what artists do right we had this
it can the kick start a conversation
we're talking about oh this is tech this
is art to me it's like okay you know
maybe different species but basically
the same genus here's what people are
here's what they're doing whether it's a
technologist whether it's an inventor
whether it's an artist they're giving
people something they didn't know that
they were missing that's what artists do
and so there's a body of research on
motivation that shows that certain kinds
of rewards and motivation what I call an
if-then reward if you do this then you
get that they don't work so well for
creative tasks and other kinds of work
other kinds of motivators work better
but let's look in particular at this
question of what motivates artists here
are people poets give the world
something it didn't know it was missing
painters do sculptors do musicians do
theatrical artists do what motivates
artists here's one interesting
experiment done by interesting study
done by a woman named Teresa Amabile at
Harvard Business School a few years ago
she and some colleagues got 23 artists
painters and sculptors 23 artists
painters and sculptors and she had them
give randomly select ten of their
commissioned works and ten of their non
commissioned works tell you with me
commissioned and non-commissioned work I
had not that complicated ten
commissioned works ten non commissioned
works that's 20 works of art 23 artists
460 works of art paintings works on
paper sculptures she brings them into a
room kind of like this and she brings in
a group of art experts they don't know
where these works of art came from
460 works of art the experts museum
curators art historians other artists
gallery owners I want you to evaluate
these works of art here's what Professor
Modula and her colleagues said our
results were quite startling now most of
you probably don't read as many social
science journals as I do but if you for
those of you who do you realize that
this is about X exuberant as these guys
get okay our results were quite
startling here's what she said the
commissioned works were rated as
significantly less creative than the non
commissioned works yet they were not
rated as different in technical quality
let me put it that's interesting a few
of you are nodding about that let me put
it a little more clearly the Commission
works in the non commissioned works on
technical quality they were pretty they
were similar
they were good remember these are people
making a living in the fine arts you
know anybody who makes a living as a
sculptor to make a living as a sculptor
you got to be a freakin good sculptor
right so the technical quality of the
works whether it's commissioned or non
commissioned work is identical if not
identical similar similar very very high
but over and over again it was the non
commissioned works that were deemed more
creative now this is a little bit
startling because we say what we have to
incentivize people to create we have to
incentivize people to innovate in here
and what are the Commission's but an
incentive I'll give you $1,000 to do a
painting but here when they have no
incentive at all they're doing more
creative work this is a little bit of a
puzzle so she goes back and she
interviews these artists and here's what
they tell her
there are commissions and there are
commissions here's one kind of
commission hey I'll do let's say tell me
your first name Claudia Claudia is a
you're an artist now are you an artist
you can't all there you go alright thank
you for sitting in the front row cloudy
is an artist you're a painter Claudia is
it your painter Claudia so I can give
you two different kinds of commissions I
can give you a commission Claudia and
say Claudia you're a great painter I
wanted you to have a I want to have a
painting of yours in my house I'll give
you a thousand bucks do something
amazing that's one kind of commission
the other kind of commission that I
could give to her is I could say Claudia
I want you to do a painting for my house
I love your artwork
I'll pay you at
thousand bucks but Claudia here's the
thing it needs to be about yay big I
really like horses so could have a horse
in it that'd be awesome
I've got a green sofa and it can't clash
with that oh and I need it on Tuesday
and what these artists talked about were
constraints a few constraints are fine
but once you got past a certain number
of constraints I said it's not mine
anymore I'll do a good job but I can't
do a great job I'll do I'll do something
good because I care because I want to do
a good job but I can't do anything
that's creative and disruptive because
they're too many constraints on me why
am i mentioning this two reasons one
remember what disruption is is giving
the world something it didn't know it
was missing that's a very disruptive act
right this is what artists do and
artists this research have built on some
other research do their best work in
non-commissioned conditions yet we have
a problem because if we go to our
workplaces all over North America
there's almost no non-commissioned work
almost everything people do on the job
is commissioned work but that's changing
a little bit let me give you some cool
examples let's take this company here
Atlassian Atlassian is an australian
software company and they do something
really cool once a quarter on Thursday
afternoons they say to their software
developers go work on anything you want
as long as it's not part of your regular
job for the next 24 hours do whatever
you want however you want to do it with
whomever you want to do it the only
thing we ask is that you show what
you've created to the rest of the
company on Friday afternoon in this fun
freewheeling meeting they call these
things
FedEx days because you have to deliver
something overnight it turns out that
this one day of intense undiluted
autonomy has led to a whole array of
fixes for existing software ideas for
new products improvements to internal
processes that it otherwise never
emerged Atlassian 361 days of commission
work four days of non-commissioned work
let's go to intuit let's not go to
intuit let's go to we don't want to go
to Intuit we want to go to we don't know
what that either we want to go to and to
it yes we've made it to intuit
let's go to intuit great company very
very high-performing company if you look
at it into its financial performance
over the last 20 years it's actually
quite spectacular most of you know what
into it does it makes software consumer
software TurboTax quicken QuickBooks ok
they face a challenge back you probably
remember back in the old days people
would buy consumer software in shrink on
platters and shrink wrap boxes right you
remember that okay I mean you should I
mean you should it's like two years ago
so but but very few people but you don't
buy software that there's a very forward
facing crowd here so looking at me like
well that's a strange thing when did
that happen
but now you you get it downloadable
right and so they had to migrate their
software from platters to make it
downloadable executable on computers
will who they do a great job high-fives
all around everybody psyched and then
they start hearing from the customers
hey it'd be awesome to have TurboTax on
my iPad it'd be cool to have QuickBooks
on my blackberry uh-oh
they got to go put all these things on
mobile devices and to it has had four
its engineers for a long time something
called 10% time where people spend 10
percent of the time working on whatever
they want it sounds a little Woodstock
II follow your bliss Summer of Love but
it's very strategic very hard-headed the
companies that do this kind of thing
they don't sign a way to the IP rights
to what's created during that 10% time
so here's what the head of innovation at
Intuit told me not too long ago after
our CEO declared mobile was key to our
strategy none of our business units were
able to change direction on a dime but
our employees using 10% time created
seven mobile apps before any other
formally funded mobile projects even got
started
yes 90% Commission 10% non-commissioned
let's go back a bit and talk about the
powerful this is not only groovy can we
go back to slides please
it even applies to things that aren't
software companies even powerhouses like
the Columbia credit union in Vancouver
Washington which actually and recent
told me backstage that Facebook's going
to try to buy it no I that's probably a
securities law violation but we'll deal
with that later uh it's a credit union a
tiny little credit union in Washington
State there's a young woman there named
Jen Schaffner she's a boss she heads the
customer service division at this at
this credit union she has six employees
she says to her boss I want to do a Fed
Ex stay with my employees her boss says
no she says okay I'll do something else
and so she creates something called the
genius hour we're one hour a week she
says to her staff leave the phones go
think about a better way to serve our
members go think about a better way for
me to do our job and I'll cover the
phones for you during that hour 39 hours
of Commission work one hour of non
commissioned work all kinds of awesome
ideas coming out of that all of this
leads us back we hope to these guys
Andre Guymon Konstantin Novoselov now
they have a laboratory at the University
of Manchester in the United Kingdom they
have they write grants to get money for
research
they have papers do in journals but at
this laboratory from its inception
thanks to Professor gone they have
carved out time a few hours a week for
what they call Friday evening
experiments where for a few hours every
week they just try stuff few hours every
week usually on Friday nights because it
physicists
few hours every week they just try stuff
the rules are pretty simple one can't be
anything you have funding for - it can't
be anything you wear you have a paper
due 3 according to neva Salaf you're
allowed to do whatever you want as long
as it's not boring
they made their breakthrough on graphene
not in the regular work but in their
Friday evening experiments let's back
this up for a moment they won the Nobel
Prize in Physics
alright Nobel Prize in Physics that's
pretty good right
if one of my kids called me up in 20
years and said hey Dad I just won the
Nobel Prize in Physics I would say not
bad right they won the Nobel Prize in
Physics for non-commissioned work this
is where the world is going and I urge
you to carve out some time for
non-commissioned work don't go crazy but
I'm convinced that the architecture of
the workplace the work week our work
time is going to have room for non
commissioned work but I have to offer
you a warning about this and the warning
is also exemplified by Andre diamond
Konstantin Novoselov because Andre GaN
is the only guy in history who has ever
won if we can go back one who has ever
won and the Nobel Prize and an ignoble
prize you familiar with the ignoble
prizes this is for scientific research
that cannot and should not be replicated
that's literally the what it's called
alright just to give you an idea then
ignoble prize in peace awarded last year
was to the mayor of Vilnius Lithuania
who's who said and I quote the problem
of illegal luxury cars can be solved by
running over them with an armored tank
the note the ignoble prize in medicine
was worn worn by three Norwegian
scientists for a paper titled inhibitory
spillover increased urination urgency
facilitates impulse control in unrelated
domains which by my reading of the paper
says that if you have to pee really
badly you make less good decisions and
your working memory suffers
but what was I sent no he want an
ignoble prize because he had a theory he
had a theory that since all absence all
living matter is made of atoms right all
matter is made of atoms atoms have
nuclei nuclei are nuke each nucleus
surrounded by electrons electrons don't
like magnetic fields they repel magnetic
fields right if you put a living item in
a powerful enough magnetic field we can
test this proposition if you put a
living item in a powerful magnetic field
the force of the electrons could
overcome the force of gravity and
subsequently that living item could
suspend in space that was his theory he
was right he was able to levitate a frog
go to youtube look for levies goggle leg
imitating frog you'll see a photograph
for this poor frog going uh right he was
right it was a ridiculous experiment
it's all very few problems in science it
did not advance a cause of any kind but
you know what else and he was hooted and
hollered and derided for that in front
of thousands of people at the ignoble
Prize ceremonies but you know what else
about that levitating frog that was also
a Friday evening experiment because
that's the way it works that's the way
it works Konstantin Novoselov says 90%
of those Friday evening experiments
don't work they fail this is what Dyson
was saying just now all right and here's
the thing we all love to talk let's
embrace failure failure is okay loulou
failure is an option but you know what
we frickin hate failure right you do you
hate failure we hate failure I hate
failure inside of organizations we
detest failure we resist failure but you
know what but you know what failure is
integrally linked to disruption you
cannot have disruption without failure
and I'm convinced that the way to allow
disruption and the way to allow failure
these two things that are entangled with
each other is to carve out a sacred
space for them in non-commissioned work
don't fail in your Commission work okay
don't put company money on the line
don't mess things up but you know what
we can create this non-commissioned work
as a sacred space we can do our
breakthrough stuff 90% of which isn't
going to work right
that's what Navas Olaf says but 10% of
it is going to be freaking awesome right
and you can't have one without the other
so my message to you is carve out that
time for non-commissioned work allow
that failure in here's what gaim says
human progress has always been driven by
a sense of adventure and unconventional
thinking which leads me to the moral of
this story the moral of this story the
moral of this story the message of this
conference maybe even the meaning of
life is this if you really want to
disrupt the world you have to levitate
some frogs thanks for your time